[Musique]
bonsoir mes petits amis nous l'aurons
europe et un instant nounours j'explique
d'abord à tous les enfants que ce soir
nous n'avons pas le droit de parler et
que nous allons seulement chanter locaux
1 2 ouah le jeu commence tout le monde
chante à toi nounours au propre nom
justement alors sur la terre je suis
bien content
deux morts cette recette qu'on attend
quand je l'entends je suis content c'est
la saison sèche qualifier nous on va
nous accompagner à remonter ce qui est
plus joli manège broker sur les chemins
de moi
on ira jouer aux anneaux on regardera
les autos ont au contraire à des amis
[Musique]
qui sommes nous aurons de hocine nous
nous fierons chouchou de combien tu sais
que nous menions sûr et je te défie
google
après on fera petit gué et
aurora se reposer tous les jeunes après
le dîner
on ya vitesse coucher monsieur nounours
tiens tiens bon avec tous les petits
garçons avec les petites filles aussi
nounours tu es gentil notre chéri à vous
me faites un trou plaisir alors je vais
vous dire
voilà c'est simple tout bonnement
j'adore les enfants et nous tenons à lui
dans sa main ne nuit ni moi nous nous y
conduire revient bientôt j'espère bien
ah oui nous nous revient bon je viendrai
aux eaux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
lens que nounours ah bien tout est un et
qu'enfin il me rejoint lorsqu'il remonte
sa grande échelle que nous partons dans
le ciel lorsque notre nuage samba ba
prenait lé et nicolas
se tournent chacun de leur côté sur leur
petit oreiller et jeu
les a songé à tous les enfants
que la lune fait
et v
et oh
demain
il y en a qui suce
or noir d'autres qui mordent leurs draps
la lune riz en l'air
dans l aime bien les enfants
je ne
de quels beaux gosses est elle leur
glisse à l'oreille
keller dit elle on se crée tout bas
vraiment je ne sais pas
mais moi je sais qu'à tous les
je dis bonne nuit
bonnes bases
[Musique]
en
vaud
[Musique]